okay so I'm going to be really honest
and transparent with you I don't know if
Caitlyn Jenner's candidacy for the
California gubernatorial recall election
is a serious campaign or a publicity
stunt I actually can't tell I'm having
trouble determining it for myself and
part of the reason I can't tell is that
every interview that she does is so
bizarre and so disconnected from reality
and it transmits not only no actual
understanding of the political issues
but not even an interest in appearing to
understand the political issues that
part of me sort of hopes it's merely a
publicity campaign because as a
political campaign it's completely
pathetic it's in theory a pretty
interesting candidacy a republican trans
woman running supporter of trump despite
endless hostility from Trump to the
trans Community uh very much hostility
from trumpists to the trans community
and in fact the last time I covered a
Caitlyn Jenner interview many of you
were super interested in it the last
clip about one of her interviews got
over a million views was on YouTube that
wasn't even that long ago so Jenner is
interviewed again this weekend now that
the recall is happening in California
interviewed by judge Janine Pirro on Fox
News and I have to tell you I am again
questioning Caitlyn's connection to
reality she seems not even connected to
the most fundamental and basic facts on
the ground in this first clip somehow I
mean again the enemy is George Soros how
can it be that it's it's always George
Soros let's start with the first clip
killing me in on how George Soros has
been funding all these all these lawyers
at lowen's very liberal lawyers
yes yes and you know this bill very well
um and he keeps wanting them to getting
him giving as much money as they want
because he figures he's got to change
this country from the bottom up he wants
to destroy this country
so there it is it there is no campaign
at which a republican can't interject
the idea that George soros's evil
intentions are being uh promulgated and
perpetuated at every level with his
money and lawyers and of course of of
course we can get into is this just more
thinly veiled anti-Semitism I don't even
think we need to because we have so many
other things to talk about you might
have also noticed that at the bottom of
the screen there was a quote of Caitlyn
Jenner saying we have to get tough on
crime whenever I hear tough on crime I
always ask which specific crimes are we
not Tough Enough on and also when get
when you say get tough what do you mean
is it we're not Prosecuting enough is it
that the punishments aren't strict
enough do we need more jail time you
really have to make them tell us tell us
tough on crime is meaningless in the
abstract witch crimes and what aspect do
we need to be tougher on like if people
came to me and then say they say David
sir what crimes are we not Tough Enough
on I would say there's not enough uh
effort being put into even policing and
Prosecuting white-collar crime and then
the sentences are also not nearly harsh
enough we are too focused on Street
crime including drug related stuff and
not focused enough on white-collar crime
most fraud and embezzlement isn't dealt
with harshly enough okay so let's put
them in the position of having to tell
us exactly which crimes they're talking
about next clip
here Jenner is asked by Janine Pirro
whether sheets support Trump in 2024 and
whether Donald Trump should run
should Donald Trump run in 2024 that's
his decision would you support him if he
did if I was governor of the state of
California I would uh obviously I would
support him what now what what do you
mean as Governor what just would you
support him is the question what if you
weren't Governor there you go would you
still support him
um yes I I still would support him I I
do not like what's happening in this
country right now so then what's the
point of mentioning if I were Governor
like it's all just kind of confused and
very bizarre and then let's look at one
longer section about I don't even know
what but it gets into woke and other you
know buzzwords all right now you're
considered to be one of our nation's
greatest athletes and heroes in the
moment now is that even true yeah I
don't even know that that's true is
Caitlyn Jenner one of the greatest
athletes in American history that it
sounds strange to me it sounds like
maybe Fox news is saying that because
Caitlyn Jenner is a republican but I
don't even know I mean I'm not taking
anything away from generous uh
achievements but that strikes me as not
is not really even accurate but that's
not the point today okay across the
Finish Line in 1976 for that decathlon
some fan ran across the finish line on
the track uh and gave you a flag and you
wave that flag proudly and that became a
very iconic moment not just then but
throughout history in terms of of the
Olympics right how do you compare today
to then
boy has it changed remember that was
1976 our country's bicentennial year we
were just three weeks earlier the
biggest Fourth of July celebration the
countries ever had celebrating 200 years
right
um I've seen through the years the
deterioration of our flag of the flag
has deteriorated now I'm guessing
Caitlyn means a deterioration of respect
for the flag that that's what I assume
Caitlyn means which I disagree with but
it's all just Mumble mumbo-jumbo
confusion love of country
I still love our country oh okay we
certainly have issues but I'm a patriot
right my father my grandfather fought in
World War One you know my my dad stormed
the beaches of Normandy first boats on
364 guys in his division 60 came back
alive you know to fight for our freedoms
and I've always had that in my heart
patriotism I love this country I was
very proud to put that flag up
um but I've seen it go down to where now
we just saw this when the hammer thrower
uh disrespect our flag and then that
bothers me let's talk about Gwen Berry
you know she came in third place and she
thought it was all about her she said
they played the national anthem when
they knew that she didn't like it
um she did she understood she didn't
like yeah okay all right all right but
the United States was her ticket to
those Olympics they were the trials I
agree should she be allowed to go
forward when she's indicated that now
this is like a hyper nationalist
perspective
you are you're there because the U.S has
Sports and you were able to train in
your sport and so therefore no action
even a constitutionally protected action
uh is allowed because it's inherently
disrespectful to the fact that you
should be only great full to the United
it's a hyper nationalist idea which is
accepted without question on places like
Fox News pretty much rejects the flag
rejects the national anthem
you know what that's a tough question
why because I don't I like individual
freedoms number one I think now this is
actually the right Instinct by Caitlyn
Jenner it's the right Instinct protect
individual freedoms right
I think people like that who are going
to disrespect our flag
um to make a political statement and
maybe get more hits you know on social
media
um
technically have a right to do that
technically look at Janine's face
Caitlyn Jenner has the right Instinct
here which is it's I wouldn't even say
technically they have a right to do that
displaying 10 Flags if that's what you
want to do is a constitutionally
protected Free Speech statement and
turning away from the flag is as well
and they're equal under the law but they
we also have the right they have the
right to deserve this the consequences
that will come out of their actions
that's right and what I wish is that
Caitlyn Jenner applied this same
analysis to social media and the idea
that their free speech doesn't mean
freedom from consequences of speech and
as long as it's not a government
sanction the Olympics say you these are
the rules about how you have to address
the flag they would be they would be
able to do that and then people could
react to that by saying well I don't
like that I'll boycott the Olympics or
whatever but Caitlyn Jenner's instinct
is actually it's a Moment of clarity and
Janine doesn't like it are there enough
consequences to someone like that
excellent question and so many cases no
sometimes to become big stars for that
like getting commercials for Nike and
things like that uh that bothers me
tremendously this woke that world that
we're living in right now
um uh is I don't know
honestly I don't know how we move
forward we have to move forward and be
strong we have to move forward with love
of country so there is the conflict
where Caitlyn actually has the right
Instinct about individual freedom but
still has to sort of kowtow to woke is
bad and how do we even deal with woke so
a confused interview an interesting
Moment of clarity it's the moment where
Janine Pirro pushed back the most but
big picture continued confusion sort of
coming out of the pseudo candidacy of
Caitlyn Jenner let me know what you
think our sponsor purevpn is having a
huge 14th anniversary sale offering
everybody in my audience a subscription
for under three bucks a month
purevpn is a service I trust because it
has more servers than any other VPN on
the market and it's the only VPN with an
always-on third party audit to verify
that your internet activity is not being
logged purevpn keeps me anonymous online
keeps me safe from hackers government
surveillance any websites trying to
track me and it lets me also access
awesome streaming content which wouldn't
otherwise be available in my country on
platforms like Netflix and a whole bunch
of others I can stay logged into purevpn
on up to 10 of my devices at the same
time and it's so easy to use you click
two buttons to set it up you need no
computer expertise at all you can get
purevpn at a huge discount just 288 a
month when you go to davidpackman.com
VPN the link is right under this video
and you'll get an additional 14 off when
you use the coupon code hbd14